There's a great deal we do not yet know
about luminescence,
about the way in which
animals produce light.
But we know approximately
how it goes.
They have in their bodies a fluid
which is the equivalent of this.
And then they have in glands a fluid
And they're able to squirt in little jets,
almost, the equivalent of this
into the equivalent of that.
And let me show you what happens
when you do that.
Let's have the lights down.
Now then.
One, two, three, squirt.
Do you see that? Shall I do it again?
You see a blue light?
Now as a matter of fact,
I know it's terrible thing to say
but I think that is so marvellous,
let's do it on a bigger scale.
[LAUGHTER]
[CLAPS HANDS TOGETHER]
Right.
[SOUND OF STIRRING GLASS]
Lights down again.
[LAUGHTER]
One, two, three
[AUDIENCE GASPS]
How about that?
[APPLAUSE]